[Music]
my name is Abe Haskins I'm a developer
programs engineer which is a very fancy
very googly title to mean I make
examples and samples and I give talks
and I help people understand firebase
and Google Cloud as I usually do I'd
like to get some context about who I'm
talking to
because although obviously we have
rehearsed hundreds of times I would
still like to tailor things to my
audience so everyone is on the same page
so for some context
who knows what firebase is all right
that's pretty good that's pretty good
I've been working for firebase for like
five years and five years ago I'd say
that and no one would raise their hand
and I just cry this is already off to a
better start than that with me is Jen
person she's a developer advocate on the
firebase team as well right yes hello
and we're gonna be talking about going
from a workstation to a production waste
service this is going to be a pretty
fast talk we're going to cover a lot of
ground and we're going to basically
cover everything you need to be thinking
about as you're building with server
lists and these concepts really are kind
of as you're building in general but
they're specifically tailored to service
and throughout it'll also be
specifically tailored to firebase as I
mentioned for both firebase engineers so
all the examples and samples they will
be firebase related but the concepts are
applied or whatever you're building with
all the systems on Google cloud that
we'll talk about work just as well if
you're running on container engine or
compute engine
but because we're from firebase it's all
gonna be based around firebase so our
goal when we're building if you're
building anything you want to build
confidently but this is extra true in
the service world because as we shift
towards bare metal and things that I
have control over and I can probably
physically go and touch to server lists
where we're not even sure how many
machines I'm running on we don't get
that level of granularity we need to
build systems where we have confidence
so that means confidence in the code
confidence in banking changes to the
code confidence and having it out in the
wild making sure it's running well
confidence
something goes down I will fix it or I
will know about it confidence that
someone else will fix it
in all likelihood these are all things
we have to be confident about and this
is a general theme of this presentation
how do we go from starting a project
having it in production live costing us
a lot of money confidently and this is
broken down to the six core segments
first thing we're going to talk about
briefly code how to make good code some
things about circle I said I think a lot
of people get wrong when they're
thinking about code then we're gonna go
into testing and general talk about how
we think about testing and service will
go into deployments and roll back some
of the tools some of the things we
announced this week about how to do
deployments better how to fix issues
when you deploy something broken because
regards as how good your tests are
there's still a pretty good chance
something bad will get into production
eventually so we want to prepare for
that then we'll move on to configuration
environments dealing with staging
environments and production environments
how to think about how your code relates
to that then we'll move into monitoring
how to keep an eye on what's happening
how to know if something breaks how to
feel confident that if something breaks
you'll hear about it preferably before
your consumers do and then we'll move
into figuring out how much stuff costs
dealing with predictability and our
pricing and all of that fun dollar bills
stuff let's start with code again I'd
like to keep an eye you know get a sense
of who's in this room how many people
consider themselves engineers ok most
everyone how many consider themselves
Java Script or node engineers first ok a
lot fewer so this is good
generally when we're talking about
service we're talking about a couple of
languages I say JavaScript specifically
because it's one of the most popular
back-end languages for new applications
if we're talking about classical
enterprise applications obviously it
doesn't have that same penetration but
that's alright in service we're almost
always talking about JavaScript
sometimes we're talking about Python and
then sometimes we're talking about Java
or go in some situations but most of the
time we're talking about these languages
that supposedly let you iterate quicker
by being more dynamic that's the first
thing I want to talk about this idea
that these languages like
JavaScript and Python allow you to
iterate faster and this is something
that I intensely do not believe this
idea that when you're building with
service that you are going to use these
languages that are kind of flexible and
loose to build up these great systems
because you know server list is very
contained we get these nice little
reusable functions and modules we can
move around we might think that they're
maintainable and that they can scale
with these languages that don't work
very well at scale and that's simply not
true so let me let me give you an
example here's a JavaScript function
imagine you're a new member of your team
you know a mid-level engineer you just
hired in and you give them a simple task
or write a function that says is a given
user privileged and again this is what I
was talking about where we're saying
this is a firebase snippet this is a
conversation with the firebase real time
database if you're not familiar that's
okay because remember most of your new
engineers probably won't be they won't
be familiar with any given specific
technology you're using so in this case
if I'm trying to write a function that
returns true or false this might be
something similar node right they come
in and they look at your other code and
they do like alright this looks like the
gist of it I'm looking up a user's role
checking if they're an admin or turning
what the value from the database is but
the problem is JavaScript has a bunch of
issues here and JavaScript is really not
good at telling people about this and
when we go to write this code we're
already losing confidence by not being
able to write new code confidently
before we compile it before we build it
and run it and test it we're already
losing confidence and here's a bunch of
things that this function is missing it
doesn't have a return statement it's
missing an invocation on database
database is not a field it's a method
and that string that says valid it's
it's supposed to be value and of course
you say these are very specific of
course I'd be able to tell you know if I
was really familiar with the firebase
SDK or if you're really good at
JavaScript you might have caught the
return thing or something like that but
you're still not gonna be in a very good
situation if you're putting someone new
onto the team and as you're growing and
as you're onboarding more and more
people they're gonna keep hitting these
snags again and again and if you're an
excellent JavaScript engineer which I'm
sure some of you are I'm sure some of
you are world
yes JavaScript engineer you might be
able to write JavaScript but stills and
works great but 90% of developers won't
be able to so we have to talk about a
different solution avoiding the idea of
faster iteration by loosely typed
languages and things like that we can go
and move into typed languages and the
people who aren't JavaScript developers
who aren't Python developers they
already know this they understand the
power that comes with a great typing
system and that's something that I feel
very very strongly about specifically in
regards to confidence and fast iteration
people look at these languages that are
more verbose and they say well I really
don't want to have to declare what I'm
returning I don't want to have to script
out these models that fit my JSON
strings but this all comes back to bite
you this is like in a small time save in
the beginning for an extremely large
expense again and again and again over
on so how do we deal with this really
I'm not gonna convince any JavaScript
developer or Python developer to move
and start writing go it's probably not
gonna happen overnight
but I can probably convince them to try
typescript
typescript compiler JavaScript it works
in every situation that JavaScript works
in but you get all these lovely
guarantees that come with type languages
here's the same function that we showed
before with all these issues and every
issue here even if it only take you a
few minutes to figure out every single
one of these issues
typescript can catch as you're typing so
here's the same function rewritten in
typescript
it looks basically the same there's
async await operators in there and
that's modern JavaScript if you were
running on a new version of node you'd
still get that if you're running in a
modern enough browser you would get that
but with typescript since it's compiled
you get that for free everywhere without
having to worry about it
then we add in that string and boolean
just say hey this is what I'm trying to
return here this is my end goal
and because of that this function can
now be smart enough to say wait you're
not returning something wait you were
supposed to invoke database wait once
only takes the string value of child
edit or child removed so Val could never
be an option so all those things that
may have just taken you a couple of
minutes to figure out have now been
removed and are immediately resolved by
typescript and this is actually more
verbose InTouch
needs to be we can save some time you
can infer types in some places but you
know generally I try to write it a bit
more verbose late like this so my point
is the typescript
gives us a confidence about what we're
doing and as we build up these api's
internally and we build up these systems
internally in libraries that you know
different teams are importing and
different people are using we really
need to make good guarantees to everyone
else that we will keep we want to say to
people in other teams in our company hey
if you use this library here's a
guarantee I'm making to you and these
these things are things that typescript
give you touch script also gives you
something really amazing it gives you
Auto completion and again if I'm talking
to someone who wrote a lot of Java or
wrote a lot of go you're like yeah
obviously alpha completion is great and
you might not realize how horrible Auto
completion is in JavaScript and other
dynamic languages it is like a best
guess and it's because Java scripts are
really hard to statically analyze it's
in borderline impossible to tell what's
gonna be on an object at runtime so
figuring out how to do good auto
completion is basically impossible
typescript on the other hand is
excellent so now we get a bunch of the
speed of JavaScript a bunch of the
iteration ability the flexibility all
the support of all these great libraries
plus great auto completion that says hey
here's exactly what is on these
different methods and this is the actual
auto completion from the firebase SDK we
ship types to grip with touch group
definitions with all of our libraries
along with most of the cloud libraries
so instead of having to hop to
documentation and things like that we
get great auto completion in our editor
side note I highly recommend writing
typescript in webstorm other people like
vs code or other options there's a ton
of things to pick from but the same
auto-completion is everywhere because
it's very easy like I said before
talking about guarantees all right
because if I make a guarantee about
something that's a level of confidence
that I can go forward with and I can put
out to other teams and I can say hey I
guarantee my library is gonna expose
this interface so if you depend on me it
is going to match this interface that's
defined by typescript that says hey it
has these methods and it returns these
things when we're talking about taking
on dependencies and again as a
JavaScript developer you are incredibly
prone to doing this we take on
dependencies all the time
there's a reason a node modules folder
has like 17 billion folders in it it's a
ridiculous dependency tree and every
single one of these is a risk it's a
security risk it is a risk in terms of
that library not getting updated it's a
risk in terms of the amount of effort
that you're gonna put into understanding
that library only for it to change so I
want to talk about how typescript helps
us understand how to pick what
dependencies to choose because we're not
gonna get away not having any
dependencies it just doesn't work like
that but we can improve our situation
immensely so I mention you're in a
situation where you want it to go find a
library that would print colors to your
terminal like you're like things are
good printing green things are bad
printer bread and you search NPM the
package management repository for node
and you say all right show me some
colors and you get 3,600 packages back
and let's pretend somehow you filled it
out the other 3,600 is like those aren't
the ones I want and you come down to two
that are common libraries people use to
colorize things in the terminal one is
called colors and one it's called chalk
if you look at the usage of these two
libraries colors is the winner more
people depend on colors in chalk no
question but that's not all we have to
be concerned with is colors a good
library for us to use or is chalk so if
we hop into the code for these and look
at the package.json file you'll see a
bunch of different gibberish and what
we're looking here for is a type script
reference of some form either the word
typescript or the extension TS the word
types or a DTS file all of these are
signs that the developer who has created
this library hasn't only created the
library and updated it within the last
couple years since typescript is again
popularity but they've also put in the
effort to make a guarantee to you to say
my library is going to match this
typescript definition that I'm providing
you so this is a level of confidence
because now we're saying right this
developer cares enough to at least try
to make me a guarantee and if you look
all three colors is no type script there
is no reference to type script if you
look at rock though on the other hand
there is there's this little DPS file
and if you go and if you had spent years
of your time like hanging out in the
node community and talking to developers
you would know chalk is the preferred
way colors has issues like prototype
Belote and crap like that but chalk is
nice clean simple and up-to-date so
these are the types of things the
typescript kind of gives you a feel for
the people who care about being
confident and having consistency in what
they're doing are generally writing type
script over JavaScript these days so
that's kind of my whole whole spiel
about typescript that entire section was
just right with typed languages type
scripts obviously great if you're
writing JavaScript but in general just
please don't use dynamic languages for
this type of stuff it doesn't it's very
very very hard to scale well and with
that I'll move I'll hand it over to Jen
to talk a bit about testing your code as
you're writing it thank you
testing in serverless has a lot of
things in common with testing in other
environments that has some things that
are unique but I would say what's most
important to start with is most people
are not testing enough and you know a
good place to start is just to make sure
that you are writing some tests there
really isn't any consistency among
different businesses and anyone who
comes into your company you cannot you
cannot assume that they are going to
test things the same way that you do
right now so a good place to start if
you're not testing I'm gonna pretend I
didn't hear that please just write some
tests after you're done with that second
step is integrating those tests into the
development lifecycle you want to make
things as simple as possible so that
your developers are going to test
regardless the more simple and
consistent things are the easier it's
going to be to run those tests you want
to be as automated as possible so we can
start by encouraging developers to write
tests by removing some of the cost of
writing those tests and what do I mean
again we have an example here that's
written in cloud functions for firebase
but this is going to be the same kind of
thing no matter what your server Louis
environment is here I have a very
lengthy function and what it does is
when a message is written to the
database it sends a notification to
everybody that's in that room and lets
them know that a message was sent it
also checks to make sure that it doesn't
send a notification the person who
originally wrote the message because
they know that they wrote it but this is
really hard to check it's really hard to
test this besides just doing a simple
deploying it and then actually you know
writing things to the database it's
really not ideal for testing so it's
better to write your functions like this
so what is it that I've changed about
this here I have a top-level namespace
and in cloud functions this enables me
to trigger functions in a couple of
different ways now I have the automatic
trigger which occurs when that write
happens and I have an HTTP trigger so
that I can run it manually I've also
moved the functions specific logic away
and added a centaurum function and you
notice that just has a room ID and some
text and that enables me to test things
without needing any unique objects that
may be present in your service
environment so for instance in cloud
functions you might have something like
a document snapshot but rather than
having to handle that unique object it's
so much easier if you can just test like
this using a string so the second part
is running your tests tests simply
cannot be optional if they are they're
going to get stale and they're not going
to be run consistently even if you are a
great developer if it's late at night
and you're trying to patch something
there's a good chance that at some point
you're going to forget and that's gonna
be the point where there's going to be
an error so it's a good idea to use
something like pre deploy hooks which
are available in cloud functions and
other service environments here you have
a test that has to be run in order to
put something in in
to staging or in to deploying this means
that if this fails it will not actually
go live and you can also run this from
your continuous integration or
continuous deployment environment which
is great so even if you're not running
it from your workstation if you have
somewhere else that automatically runs
it you can still run these hooks first
and it's gonna talk a little bit more
about continuous integration but first
if you want to know more about testing
here's a couple talks that we suggest
release with confidence testing
debugging and monitoring in a
surveillance world and also GCP and the
future of software testing so I know we
just covered a couple of really basic
examples but again keep in mind that you
want tests to be simple and automatic
all right let's talk about deployment
and rollback Thanks so imagine you've
written some code using typescript
obviously because I've sold you on it
and you've written some tests and that
run automatically you know you can't
deploy anything without passing these
tests that's great let's go a step
further and say how are we deploying our
code how are we getting our code from
our workstation to our servers and this
is a question that there's a lot of
different answers to if you've been
programming for a minute like I have you
might think back to the days of
uploading SFTP files like dragging your
PHP index for dot PHP over or whatever
but today we have a lot of great options
for doing things in a way that are very
autonomous this is a recurring theme
autonomous brings confidence and that is
easy to roll back when something goes
wrong because one of the biggest
problems with having a deployment
process that isn't automated is that if
something goes wrong you have to go and
redo what is probably like a five or ten
step process at least with the stress of
knowing something is broken in
production and there's generally like
one person who actually understands the
script that does the deploy and then
there's a bunch of people who just read
the instructions this is a big bus
factor involved too so I want to talk
about this really cool tool called cloud
build this is our continuous integration
continuous deployment tool we have as
part of Google Cloud so if you're
already hosting all your code
Google cloud like I'm sure you are and
you're already deploying to Google cloud
that I'm sure you are then we can use
cloud belt to kind of merge those two
steps this is a really easy to setup
tool and what you do is you go you make
your cloud repo and you say whenever I
commit to my production branch or my
master branch or my staging branch just
run like an arbitrary set of commands up
in the cloud for me and here we have a
whole log of me deploying a server you
know it says oh you're triggering by
pushing the master you can see some of
the builds failed because there were
issues in the tests some of them
succeeded and actually got deployed up
in this case I'm pushing to container
registry so I'm actually building a
docker container using this tool all on
the servers so when I'm locally
developing I have my own setup for you
know doing the development but I'm not
actually ever building the docker
container I'm not remembering what those
commands are that's written down in this
fancy file called a cloud build ya know
now sadly it's a little small up here
it's a little hard to read but it's
basically broken up into three steps
just like building and deploying a
container on go cloud would be first
rebuild the container then we push it on
up to our container registry and then we
swap out our kubernetes deployment to
say hey use this new image or you use
this new container and this is just like
a simple format this could be anything
you know we could compile our go code in
here we could compile or a typescript in
here we could ship up firebase functions
from here we have a bunch of options but
the flexibility here is is part of the
important part right because you can
since you can put anything in here you
can put any series of build steps you
can go sub permissions you can change
stuff it's really important that you put
as much of your deploy process into like
this nice written down file as possible
because now to deploy to production all
I do is push to master and or production
whatever branch you want and this is
nice because if you already have a good
workflow for auditing code changes which
I'm sure you do you know somebody goes
and adds a feature they have to go do a
PR it has to be reviewed and then it
gets merged in you get all the safety of
that going in to your pushes to
production it's just really clean it's
really really nice and when you get a
build it automatically goes and parses
that file and as you can see we have
three steps here building the docker
container pushing the docking container
and up
the kubernetes cluster and it says how
long is we're taking it gives me other
metadata about the build shows me the
logs all about useful stuff and that's
super cool but what's really cool is
when I break something when something
somehow gets past my tests and get past
all my code and something's broken in
production we have this really tiny
rebuild button up there and since we
have a log of every time I push to
production we can go back and say all
right last week's push worked fine there
was clearly something wrong in this week
we're panicking go hit the rebuild
button from last week rebuilds the image
and according to this about you know
three minutes and thirty seconds later
that's live in production again the
current version has now been replaced
with an older version that we knew was
working so instead of having to remember
how to like get revert back a week check
out the right commit rerun all the
deploy steps you just hit a button and
we're good we're back into a safe spot
and this is the biggest benefit for me
because everyone does make mistakes and
again if you're scaling up a team people
are going to make these types of
mistakes so automating the build process
so they're not accidentally making a
mistake in that automating the
deployment process making it safe when
they do make issues this is all a huge
gain in confidence because it's a safety
net it lets us know if something's going
if something does go wrong it lets us
know we can confidently fix it
we have a whole talk about this if
you're interested in this concept I
think this is probably my single most
important tip in this whole talk is use
CICE tools go look at this talk from
zero to production the production ready
deployment pipeline for your next app I
think it's this afternoon it might be
tomorrow either way I check it out this
is really really useful stuff next we're
going to talk about dealing with
configuration environmental or
environmental variables staging
environments that type of stuff so I'll
hand over to Jen thank you so
historically we know that your
applications are going to need some sort
of environmental configuration if it's
API keys or there might be some sort of
credentials that you have to pass and
these are probably going to be unique
for your staging and your production
versions of your application so it's a
good idea to use some sort of
environmental initialization what do you
mean by that a lot of these are either
API keys are stored in JSON files
and you might usually have like a path
that you're using slash staging slash
whatever Jason and maybe you have one
for production and then you go into your
code and you have two different versions
where they're both pointing to different
locations and that's very error-prone
and you don't also want to commit that
secret information as well so for
example again going back to firebase as
an example we have something that you
can do in firebase hosting which is this
firebase / UJS and this is made
automatically by the environment what
this enables you to do is take the same
exact code and deploy it either to your
staging or your production and it will
just work because it's using that
initialization that's created by
firebase so it's based on the project in
which it is located
now basic initialization isn't enough
we're going to want to be able to store
more data in our environment then you
know there it's great that firebase
provides that for you but not everywhere
has all of that automatic including with
in firebase there certain things that
aren't just automatic so take this as an
example
again we have a cloud function and it is
a non Creek one so it's going to be
triggered when something is written to
that particular location in the database
and we need an API token to make a
request to a URL notice the token says
functions dot config and then you know
your P your API token functions config
is the environmental configuration
provided by firebase cloud functions for
firebase and this enables you to put
pretty much like a arbitrary strings in
there so you can have tokens and in in
this example you could again have a
token that's for your production version
and use the same exact code in both
locations
the purpose of all these things is to
make things as simple as possible and
remove any make it less error-prone
so again if you just have that same
configuration and then you just add that
based on your different versions of your
application you can not worry about
having different versions of your app
I'm gonna pass things back over to Abe
to talk about monitoring your
do you deployed it alright so we have
almost shipped a project completely into
production we're very close we've
committed it you know
we've deployed it with our CI tool we've
loaded it up using the initialization
from the environment and now we need to
keep an eye on it and this is again a
part that people really seem to start
failing at because it's it's pretty
tough there's a lot of angles you have
to come at in order to keep an eye on a
running application but we make it
easier with Google Cloud because anytime
we're talking about keeping an eye on
something we're talking about
stackdriver stackdriver is a really
powerful tool I don't claim to
understand all of it but there's a few
games we can get just by doing a few
simple things to keep an eye on our
application and to feel more confident
when it's running in our production
environments I mean it's pretty talk
about enhancing logging we all know the
lowest common denominator for logging
out anything it's just like console that
logged about dot log system dot out dot
print line right like it goes to the
standard output maybe we save it to a
file that's great but it's actually
horrible it's not great at all because
as soon as something starts going wrong
it becomes very difficult to look at
these logs and gain any insight out of
them this becomes especially true if you
have like a multi-tenant environment
with a lot of asynchronous stuff
happening and these logs just kind of
mush together so if you're looking at
one issue that went wrong you're gonna
be like well is this log from a
different request what what's happening
here so I want to talk about how we can
get that way better we can get a much
better situation without any code
changes and so if we're logging things
out in cloud functions or firebase or
many of our other service offerings you
get a log like this and I want to stress
that this is just from a normal console
dot log in our JavaScript this is not
anything special we're not importing any
SDK you can see we have the actual text
of our log all the way to the right like
that text without any coloring on it is
the actual output and starting from the
left we have a timestamp that we get
automatically we have a name that name
is the function that it was invoked to
cause this log so for example if I
thought one of my specific endpoints was
failing a lot
so hey only show me logs for at some
point that's helpful but what's even
more helpful is these crazy numbers
right to the right and what that is is
the invocation ID so every time I hit an
endpoint it gets its own invocation ID
all the logs get tagged with that so if
I want to go and see the lifecycle of
one of one specific call to one specific
endpoint I can click on that filter it
down it builds up that whole query up
there automatically and I can see the
entire lifecycle of my execution and we
can see here we start the execution we
run some code we print something out we
get a result and then the function ended
it said took five thousand three hundred
milliseconds about five seconds to run
and that's the entire lifecycle so now
we're not dealing with all those logs
we're not dealing with a text file that
we're trying to like grep through it is
so much cleaner to use stackdriver
logging to parse our logs to slice and
dice that information it's a no-brainer
especially because it's not a code
change and again this comes in across
like all Google Cloud projects if you
are just setting this up you can get a
ton of benefit from it but we can move
beyond logging this type of logging is
extremely reactive it's like something
happened somehow we found out about it
and then we went and started looking at
our logs but we can go a step further
and we can get alerted when something
goes wrong so the same ability for us to
know you know for it to capture those
logs and throw them out it can also
capture stack traces and it can tell us
about them so this is stack driver error
reporting as an active or error
reporting is a proactive tool as soon as
something happens it's watching all the
time and as soon as something happens it
says hey it was an error in this case
you can see I've had a few errors in
those same requests cool for fail cool
methods and if we click on one of those
we get a whole bunch of insight about
that specific error it links us to the
line of code that caused it it tells us
how often it happens when it last
happened of course it gives us just a
normal stack trace to debug on and again
no code changes here this is just
running in our service environment and
turning this on we get all this benefit
so we can set this up we can say hey so
I me a text message hit me up on the
Google cloud mobile app you know send it
over to Page your duty to route to the
right person all these options as soon
as something goes wrong
so this is a great way to say all right
I know if something goes wrong if
something throws I will know about it I
know I can go very easily going to the
individual invocation that caused that
throw in like a few seconds I can get
those logs that's super helpful and the
combination of those things gives us
again more confidence but we're still
not quite there right like that's more
proactive that's like getting closer to
the error but really we want to catch
these things before they happen we want
to keep an eye on our system and say if
anything goes wrong or as a or is going
to go wrong I should know about it and
this is where stackdriver
monitoring comes up let's doctor over
monitoring looks a bit different than
the rest of the cloud console one
because mine is named black but two also
because it is kind of outside the
console because it can run against your
AWS resources and other things like that
but you can see here we have two
specific little dropdowns up there one
set the cloud function and one set to
execution count and in here is
everything about your Google cloud setup
it's like your cloud storage data it has
information about how many App Engine
instances you're running how many
compute engine no CPU hours you're using
all sorts of crazy stuff you can just go
in here chart them in different ways
build up dashboards and do all sorts of
fun stuff like that you can build those
big screens where you're like oh look at
their colored lines I know what those
mean all through this tool and we're
just throwing this information out for
you and it's super super useful so here
we have two lines we have this blue line
and this pink line the pink line is
obviously much lower than the blue line
and this is to be expected because that
blue line is the front end function that
actually serves up content and the pink
line is the one that requests it and
actually builds up the content to be
served and there's a big difference in
the invocation count because there's a
caching layer between them the pink line
is expensive and slow so it doesn't get
called as much but we can imagine a
situation where something went wrong
right where those note lines started to
converge where our cache was failing
we're expiry was too short or something
like that and we could easily set up a
policy to alert us if that case started
to become true so an example of this is
I have a cron job that runs to deal with
this specific cache the daily cache
cleaner job runs about 24 times a day
run and if at any point the threshold
for how often it's being executed falls
below once an hour I want to know about
it because that means for some reason
something happened that made my cron job
not run I don't know what it was it
might not matter but something happened
maybe the network flickered maybe the
job aired out for whatever reason and if
we look at this we can see there's been
a few incidents over time it's texted me
three times and said hey just so you
know the cron job didn't run and again I
don't particularly care like the cron
job will run again in the next hour and
as long as it resolves that's fine and
the great part about stackdriver is that
if it resolves it'll text me again and
say never mind it's all good so we have
this situation where now if something
goes wrong we can easily debug it with
stackdriver logging if something new
happens we will get alerted through
error reporting and before anything bad
happens we will keep an eye on it with
stackdriver monitoring this is just just
viewing confidence all over the place
because we have such a good idea of what
our application is doing and if I'm not
looking at the screen if I'm not in the
office I can feel really safe that I'm
looking at this from all angles and
keeping an eye on what's going on the
last thing we're going to talk about is
pricing I'll hand over to Jen thank you
so when it comes to pricing of server
lists what I'm really talking about is
not just the money involved but just the
whole cost what are you really buying
into and when I think about you know
buying into any system serverless being
one of those I think about soy sauce and
the reason is I watched a video on how
soy sauce was made and did you know it's
actually pretty basic right it's water
and salt and soy beans and I think yeast
I think that I could probably do it
myself I've been cooking for a long time
right maybe you can see where I'm going
with this
if I want to make dinner and dinner
include soy sauce I can either spend a
really long time making soy sauce and
probably not make it that well or I can
make dinner so when you're buying into
server lists you're basically paying
someone else to take care of that system
for you so you have to ask yourself what
is it that you're trying to make what
are you trying to build does it really
make sense to make something from the
ground up yourself or does it make sense
to invest and so
nobody else making it because yeah that
initial cost is going to be more
expensive and especially when you know
that system might go down it's going to
be really hard to give up that control
so I'm talking about cost as in the
price but also everything that you're
buying into so let's talk about
forecasting how do you know how much you
are going to be paying fortunately many
of these systems all Google cloud
systems at least have some sort of
calculator so you can figure out how
much you're planning on spending on it
but it has like a whole bunch of small
details in it that you might not be
familiar with
do you really know how many CPU hours
you're going to need if only there was
something that collected that
information yeah so stackdriver
fortunately collects a lot of good
details for you and you can use these to
calculate how much you're going to be
spending so yes calculators are great
but they're only one part of it you
really have to know what all those
little numbers are behind the scenes and
that's when stackdriver comes in to
really help you out now keep in mind
Google cloud has a huge variety of
different options and most apps will mix
and match not all apps should be server
less when Clyde functions for firebase
first came out I was like this solves
every problem I'm gonna make everything
work
it's got functions but certain things
just don't make sense when you have a 60
second timeout or you know you can even
up it longer than that but some things
take a long time and sometimes it makes
more sense just to have a traditional
server that's constantly running so
rather than trying to make everything
fit into serverless sometimes it's going
to be more affordable and just make more
sense to do things on a more traditional
server so don't forget that there's like
a whole suite of tools out there the
Google cloud has that may serve your
different needs it doesn't all have to
be service and also factor in the cost
of ops this sort of goes back to what I
was saying about making the soy sauce
there's a whole lot of people involved
in that process behind the scenes before
I go to the grocery store and buy it and
if I do it myself
I
really don't know that I'm not gonna
give myself botulism or Salmonella or
something there's all sorts of people
behind the scenes that are ensuring that
every single product is high quality so
when I'm buying soy sauce in the store
it's gonna be more expensive and
something similar can be said of you
think serverless so you might find that
up front it kind of seems like it's
gonna be more expensive than spinning
things yourself but you can factor in
the fact that you need fewer people to
be in charge of that ops for you
because you're basically paying to have
someone make sure that it's working all
the time
so for more info on managing cost
because this is a very important topic
of course we have a few different talks
for you to pick from managing costs and
GCP how to structure your resources
optimizing applications for scalability
while keeping costs at bay and
monitoring and forecasting your GCP
costs so if money is important which
pretty sure it is to all businesses I
would definitely check these out so
let's sort of summarize what we talked
about today we want to make sure that
your service environment is very
reliable and that you have confidence in
it so we talked about writing clean
strong code using typescript type
languages might be hard to swallow for
traditional JavaScript developers but I
agree that's having a background in
Swift I know what their benefits are and
I highly recommend checking out
typescript systematic testing is very
important you need your tests to be
automated automatic and no-brainer so
that as you're growing your team they
don't have to worry about learning your
testing technique it's built in and the
easier it is to do your tests the more
likely they are to be running instant
deployment and rollback we talked about
how it's important to have an
environment where you can automatically
rollback if there are errors in your
testing or errors in your deployment we
talked about environments and config and
setting it up so that your secret API
keys or your configurations are both
hidden and safe and also are not part of
your code so
it's it's agnostic of what version of
your code you're running we talked about
trustworthy monitoring using stackdriver
and also how that blends really nicely
into predictable pricing and thinking
about how serverless upfront can sound
more expensive but in the end it might
be the better choice for you
[Music]